hey guys I'm Ryan rides and Sark we're
gonna watch the tre two trailers here
Star Wars battlefronts the first one is
light versus dark that's exciting and
then we're gonna watch the fighter
squadron mode gameplay trailer I'm
actually really thrilled I'm thrilled -
man I really like these trailers alone I
should should know more about the games
Wow
dookey imagine a spirit coming at you
dude cool cool
Duke you freakin imagine like playing
the game and then like you're like you
just like turn around the corner and
your buddy just gets lifted you're like
oh oh dude that last part felt like real
life I was like oh my god Vader's coming
after me where those things works
getting like a little too personal and
your space oh my god this on the oculus
or more project Morpheus will be in
reticle holy [ __ ] oh yeah holy this [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] is holy fighter squadron mode
gameplay trailer your body's ready yep
you're cocked ready your [ __ ] ready to
penetrate the [ __ ] of the fighter
squadron gameplay trailer you read calm
inside of the fighter squadron gameplay
trailer Oh feels good I'm Dan sorry dude
just a point there Mason
look that good is it without it imperial
transport attempting to escape find the
target and take it out wow I really feel
like I'm a holy crap that soul men to
this transport insurance extraction
going in
look at the caucus net thing
like Starbucks right sweet look at you I
love it
we're pushing them back
Wow do you never tell me the odds take
it out
you
yes
the game looks epic Dan oh it's so good
beyond epic oh my god
dude I just [ __ ] inside of the fighter
squadron you know these last few
trailers it's like they keep teasing
that the rebels are the ones gonna lose
you know like oh that's because if they
always end it with rebels right the ones
there they're gonna be defeated man I
don't but that's not gonna happen no no
the rebel good marketing it's good
marketing honestly especially from that
second trailer I think it did a really
good job balancing between like clearly
not going like oh look oh great the
rebels are it's like yeah yeah you're
playing both sides both are gonna have
their advantages they're different
fighters and a Bubba Fett both it oh
that oh that buh buh buh buh buh buh
juices buh buh buh shrink honestly
everything graphically looks tight yeah
like at like the copy even inside the
cockpit looks better like I almost tell
the hollow ah you said the words tight
and then I was like all right just let
it go and then I said talk then you say
Connie to say something I mean this is
too much for you
Tyco cockpit was it a tight for the [ __ ]
pit sorry again come with anything with
it a type by steamer I would almost
wouldn't mind spending like a chunk of
the game just kind of like hanging
around the ship and just like taking it
all in you know it's a party again yeah
I can't I'm sorry the x-wings look real
long yeah this is great uh it looks hard
yeah looks like a hard game to play the
game looks great
penis anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Dan's gaming
channel that Seibert Channel and you
could follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and do you have a periscope
I do haven't set it up yet uh I don't
mother [ __ ] why why do I did why would I
wanted
Justin Farley hi what's up Rio rejects
I'm a big fan of your channel for up to
two years now
nice I've been watching your videos
every day you guys are hilarious and
make my day happy when I am sad
yeah you guys shout out my youtube
channel nomadic Eagle I really
appreciate it from the bottom of my
heart
mmm PS if you do shot my channel out I
could bang your boost for free Justin
Farley I would love you to bang my
boosts and the fact that you're doing it
for free is so awesome that's where you
take drumsticks and yet bang on the
testicles oh wow my really that old man
did you're missing out on what the
teenagers are into these days which is
Justin Farley one whole bang drumsticks
against my bow why would you do that
it seems very painful I know but it's
part of the erotic sensation damn I just
feel like I I will just take a high-five
well there is a highway okay nevermind I
am